[Musique]
qui parmi vous oserait dire un africain
que le manioc n'est pas de chez lui ou
un guadeloupéen que son com ou lyon
celui qui fait des pâtes chez lui ou
encore un martiniquais que son chouchou
la chine n'est pas de chez lui
je vous vois ce oui on vous dit ça tout
le monde est au courant mais oui mais
oui c'est de nous en fait non vous avez
tort vous attend parce que simplement le
court bouillon est un plat de marins du
nord qui ressemble étrangement à notre
place la chine joue chine comme son nom
l indique
ça viendrait donc pas de la martinique
et vous aurez compris que pour le manioc
c'est très loin de l'afrique puisque ça
vient d'amérique latine et donc tous ses
fruits aujourd'hui constitue une
alimentation mais aussi notre histoire
est donc dans le cadre de cet échange je
vais vous inviter à partager avec moi le
pays réel et le pays rêvé et vous allez
vous rendre compte que bien souvent je
vais vous faire décrocher mais ça c'est
normal puisque vous connaissez les
anthropologues sont pas forcément très
équilibré et mais oui faut dire ce qui
est et donc dès lors qu'on parle de
représentation on parle de
déconstruction en tain de table de ses
croyances
le père de ces substances et il est vrai
que on aurait pu passer par le prisme de
l'histoire mais non je préfère vous
inviter dans une approche plus
systémiques celles de l'archéologie et
de l'entrepôt légère alimentaire et vous
allez comprendre pourquoi on passe par
ce prisme
je vous ai dit qui oserait dire ça un
africain puisque de tout temps et a
toujours su que ça fait partie de son
corpus de bien dans notre psyché on
intègre un certain nombre de fruits
comme étant allant de soi alors que
quelque part en dichotomie on refuse de
regarder la partie plus je veux dire
voyage plus recherche
et je vais vous proposer non pas au
commencement parce que ça fait très
hollywoodien très grosse production
je veux simplement vous proposer un
petit voyage dans le temps et on va pas
le con point de départ le xvème siècle
et vous allez comprendre pourquoi je
vous parle du 15e siècle le xxe siècle
c'est à peu près la période où les
européens
enfin certains pays d'europe vont
quitter la terre pour pouvoir aller
découvrir le monde
et oui passera à voir les gazettes un
truc tranquillement cesena gain de temps
en temps ils organisent un viol mais où
il sera de créer une ambiance
construisait des églises construisait du
château les détruisaient en fait cet
intrus et plus je sais par quelques
saisies ben pourquoi on reste entre nous
devrons on va pas voyager a eu parce que
tant qu'à faire
ça pourrait être intéressant est donc
officiellement l'histoire vous dit que
les européens sont en faire la conquête
du monde pouvoir capter des richesses
l'eau et tout ça ça c'est la version
officielle et vous connais tous c'est
tout moi bien que moi que l'histoire en
fait écrit tu n'es pas le soir et donc
moi je vais vous proposer les sens réel
mais vu par le prisme de ma modeste
petite personne un peu confuse j'avoue
mais j'adore ça parce que ça permet
effectivement de temps en temps de
perdre les réalités de les récupérer
autrement je vous disais que oui
certains pays d'europe vont partir et
vous les connaissez c'est d'abord
l'espagne le portugal
vous voyez de qui je peins face qu'aux
dégâts mais oui machel la marque qu il
connaissait marco polo oui et le petit
dernier celui qui était pas bon à
l'école christophe oui colons qui par un
heureux hasard qui voulaient aller en
inde s'est retrouvé chez nous alors j'ai
toujours pas compris pourquoi
mais de sources concordantes on m'a
expliqué qu'il n'avait pas su programmé
son gps
vous aurez compris que toutes ces
personnes
tous ces navigateurs lorsqu'ils vont
partir à la conquête du monde vont
tracer les premières routes maritimes et
ses routes qui vont constituer
aujourd'hui notre héritage qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas on ne peut pas revenir
sur les faits ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
avec l'histoire
vous pouvez l'interpréter comme vous
voulez l'effet reste et donc je vous
disais à partir du moment où on pas en
découvrir d'autres territoires
forcément il y a deux applications la
première c'est pour vos populations et
la seconde pour les populations qui vont
vous recevoir d'un premier cas ça va
être de l'adaptation c'est à dire que
les populations qui vont recevoir les
nouveaux produits vont les inscrire dans
leur campus de fruits et légumes et le
deuxième ce qui vous vous intéressant
pour nous vaut faire ce qu'on appelle la
simulation par l'implantation c'est à
dire que vous allez intégrer comme
allant de soi
les produits qui vous viennent de
l'extérieur alors vous dites qu'est ce
que ça va avec tout ce que je vous ai
dit au préalable concernant au sol et de
manioc le court bouillon et à la chine
restant sur le court bouillon
aujourd'hui si vous demandez à un
incident à comment se fait un court
bouillon il va vous dire qu'il ya trois
ans courant oui oui
les puristes vont vous dire c'est
beaucoup et
les puristes vous dire ou au cou et au
coin du feu ce soir
d'accord non c'est pas maintenant on
fait pas de conditions le deuxième c'est
annoncé thomas dos et les tomates
cerises et le troisième courant plus
proche de vous tomates fraîches et sauce
tomate
sauf que je vous ai dit ça pas de laruns
du nord ça n'a rien à voir ce que je
viens de vous dire le court bouillon
ce sont des pommes de terre nouvelles
que vous faites bouillir et sur lesquels
avec des tertiales vous déposez du
poisson ça vous rappelle quelque chose
ça vous rappelle le bluff vous aurez
compris que si vous allez dire aux
guadeloupéens que ce qu'il a mangé
depuis la nuit des temps n'est pas vous
aurez compris que vous attaquez
l'essence même de ce qu'il est et c'est
tout l'intérêt de parler du pays rêvé
par opposition aux pays réel là nous
sommes dans le pays rêvé le fameux
s'acquitta dont tout le monde se gausse
mais que personne ne veut des construire
parce que ça nous rappellerait que nous
sommes la partie intéressante de la
colonisation et je pèse mes mots ce que
je dis ça ça veut dire que tout ce qui
vous paraît comme étant allant de soi
vous devriez les questionner parce qu'en
fait tout ceci est faux et qu'il vous
faut remettre du sens sur les objets qui
vous entourent mais remettre deux sens
sur l'histoire que vous connaissez alors
vous allez me dire oui mais ces peuples
lorsqu'on a été les chercher
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ici ils ont
fait ce que tu faisais ils vont
s'adapter
d'accord dans un premier temps et dans
un même temps ils vont faire part de
créativité la créativité vous la
connaissez j'aime bien prendre cet
exemple c'est la case créole
mais qu'est ce qu'une case créole vient
faire dans l'alimentation vient faire
dans le pays réel pays rêvé notre
t'inscris yonne mine de rien même s'il
payait pas de mine mais elle résister à
tout ce qui était sismique
parce qu'elle était sur pilotis dont
elle pouvait bouger l etat
monique parce qu'en fait elle résister
au vent de par son architecture et son 3
pas de prise au vent et en même temps
elle était en titre dépression parce que
le fait qu'ils des interstices entre les
bois le vent pouvait circuler et contrer
un mois à nos belles villas avec des
baies vitrées qui explose chaque fois
qu'il ya un cyclone on était à l'abri
donc vous aurez bien compris que le père
et le pays réel était dans la tête des
gens lorsqu'ils construisent vous allez
voir que pendant longtemps on va puiser
dans nos ressources parce qu'on en fait
la première des matches qu'on avait fait
6 l de s'adapter aux territoires
vous allez me dire pourquoi je vous
parle de ça encore
et en fait vous rendre compte que au fil
du temps ce pays qui était en créant
donc il faisait partie de notre adn
à mesure que nous allons avancer dans le
temps il à sentir de nous ce qui va
faire qu'aujourd'hui nous avons tenté de
la population qui sont recherche qui
aura pensé qu'en fait au sortir de
l'esclavagé il avait quitté les slaves
âge mais ils vont embrasser d'autres
formes d'espionnage je voulais c'est
très pas puisque vous les vivez suffit
de regarder passer sans façon
on s'est compris et donc une chose en
amenant une autre
il faut que nous nous questionnons sur
ce jour cette singularité d'aujourd'hui
qui est cette recherche en permanence
d'opiniâtreté de combativité
d'opposition systématique à quoi sert
tout ça puisque nous ne savons pas
quelle est notre histoire puisque nous
pensons qu'elle est écrite est en fait
elle n'est pas écrite elle était écrit
elle était entièrement par à partir des
grandes histoires de ce monde mais à
propos d'elle la nuance a son importance
parce que ça voudrait dire qu'il nous
faut réécrire une histoire en dehors de
toute reconnaissance
une autre de nos capacités pour être
révélée par une autre histoire
singulière celle du bibendum vous savez
au par le binôme cette société
commerciale créée par l'état pour
pouvoir déplacer les populations de la
voie d'eau de la martinique de la
réunion vers les grandes villes
industrielles de france dans les années
60 mais inversement de récupérer les
populations du bocage normand et de la
bretagne pour les ramener son attitude
c'est ça le but et vous allez voir ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant avec toutes ces
histoires que je vous raconte le
dénominateur commun c'est cette terre
ses terres et sans concession vous ne
pouvez pas y vivre
si vous n'avez pas la capacité créative
de vous adapter la troisième il peut
ainsi
de s'organiser mais c'est surtout de
faire résilience dans une histoire de
vie vous pouvez tout perdre en une nuit
d'accord or on se rend bien compte que
cette opiniâtreté on va la perdre au fil
des temps je vous ai dit le pays réel
il était dans l'esprit des ascendants et
des ascendants j'aime bien faire cette
nuance qui n'était pas un esclavage mais
réduits en esclavage la nuance a son
importance parce que dans le premier cas
vous aurez bien compris pendant enlèvent
leur humanité dans le second cas ça veut
dire qu'ils avaient encore plus de
créativité et c'est ça tout l'intérêt de
mon propos c'est de vous dire que pour
basculer dans le pays réel
il faut oublier un pays imaginaire et le
pays imaginaire c'est celui qui jusqu'à
maintenant nous on a permis de rester
dans imaginables la plantation parce que
nous voulons pas nous assumer il était
beaucoup plus confortable de rester à
l'intérieur où les autres prix déterminé
ce que nous devons être alors que si
vous sortiez et vous foncez c'est la
barrière vous devez vous assumez vous
devez vous assurez vous assumez c'est
assumer votre devenir vous assurer c'est
faire des projections et donc vous aurez
compris que le lien tout fait avec
l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
souvent on fait la critique de notre
rapport à l'administration ou le
rapproche d'un nouveau leader à
l'administration sans se questionner sur
une chose quel est notre part de
responsabilité souvent nous parlons
d'administration à distance sans jamais
se poser la question qu'est ce que nous
faisons quand il vient pour changer
cette réalité la question et entière
souvent nous voulons effectivement
porter une critique objective mais sans
tarder le confort de nos habits
d'insémination parce qu'il est beaucoup
plus confortable des dans cette salle
climatisée que d'avoir un éventail de
ses ventes et oui le pays réel nous
oblige à nous questionner sur ce que
nous voulons réellement pour nous mais
pour notre devenir le pays réel ne nous
demande pas une relecture du passé point
du tout ce que vous savez simple
pertinemment que les faits sont ce
qu'ils sont ils sont écrits par les
plumes du pouvoir avec les ratures et
les oublie
qui constitue le visage de l'humanité
d'aujourd'hui d'accord donc ce que nous
devons faire et je vous invite à le
faire c'est de nous dire comment faire
pour construire un nouveau mythe un
mythe fondateur qui nous permettra
d'être à l'aise qu'elle que soit là où
nous nous situerons quel que soit ce que
nous voulons faire
quel que soit ce que nous attendons de
ce territoire
parce que lui il va pas changer il vous
offrira toujours vent si vous avez trop
chaud aura dans si vous avez vraiment
chaud puis pour vous refroidir et si
après tout ça vous êtes encore d'aplomb
séisme pour briser vos idées le
territoire il va pas changer
donc la question faudra se poser c'est
comment inviter les nouvelles
générations qui n'ont plus ce pays dans
leur adn à le construire
alors j'ai quelques pistes pour vous
puisque tout l'intérêt c'est pour vos
équipiers ce n'est pas simplement de
faire un échange avec vous
la première puisqu'il a pas mieux
puisque il me paraît évident si
construire un imaginaire à partir d'une
histoire réelle
nous devons raconter nos histoires de
femmes qui quelle qu'elle soit qu'elle
soit belle ou babel de telle manière à
ce que les futures générations sont
inscrits dans le terreau de ce
territoire
et si vous êtes inscrits dans le terreau
de cette histoire vous pouvez parler
ailleurs vous êtes toujours revenir
puisque vous connaissez l'expression
ancienne
vous revenez toujours là long ah ouais
y'a pas beaucoup
la deuxième chose une chose avant une
autre la deuxième à mon sens c'est celle
de l'engagement
il nous faut nous engager pour ces
générations futures de telle manière à
ce qu'elle soit le bras armé de notre
excellence il nous faut croire dans le
rêve d'icare
mais oui qui consiste à donner à ces
générations le flambeau de vue du
renouveau le fond de l'eau qui va
illuminer irradiés de telle manière à ce
que la terre est clair le soleil je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]